soon after my return from America in the
first year of the Man n era I brought
out my first publication a Dictionary of
the English language which I called ke
Sugo and which made a beginning for my
series of later books for the next two
or three years I was more occupied with
my struggles in studying English than
teaching then in the second year of
Bankier a happy opportunity came my way
and I was able to make a visit to Europe
with the N voice sent by our government
i received an allowance of some four
hundred Ryo and as our expenses on the
tour to be borne entirely by the
ministry this income was entirely for my
own use and so being a man who did not
need much money I thought of using it
elsewhere
I took 100 Ryo of the amount and sent it
to my mother
back in our native town while I was away
in America the officious people of
nakatsu had been giving vent to rumors
about me one hood [ __ ] reported that I
was dead in the foreign country in the
full swing of the anti foreign sentiment
there was nothing we could do we had to
endure everything and keep quiet
I was really very sorry for my mother in
all this situation sending her some
money would not make up for my long
absences but still a hundred Ryo was an
enormous sum of money for both of us
never seen in all our previous lives so
I sent it to her with the best
intentions we sailed in December still
the first year of punku on an english
war vessel the Odin sent over for the
purpose of conveying our envoi
there are about 40 men in the party
among the men of general utility there
were several samurai from various clans
who had privately requested the
officials to take them along as servants
we all wore our Japanese dress with a
pair of swords in our girdles and
appeared on the streets of London and
Paris in such a tyre a sight indeed it
must have been
[Music]
[Music]
when we reached Paris and had been
formally received by the welcoming
French officials the first request we
had to make was that as many of our
party as possible be accommodated near
the chief envoy's camp because of our
number and the amount of our baggage the
heads of the mission were evidently
anxious because if different members of
the party were scattered in remote
hotels it might be inconvenient and
unsafe in a strange land the host of the
welcoming committee understood nodded
his approval and asked the number of our
party when he was told it was 40 he
replied what if you're only 40 why one
of our hotels could accommodate ten or
twenty times that number we did not
comprehend what he meant but on reaching
the hotel assigned to us we found that
he was not jesting our headquarters were
the hotel de louvre opposite the
entrance to the Imperial Palace it
really was a huge edifice of five
storeys with 600 rooms and over 500
employees more than a thousand guests
could be accommodated at one time
instead of our anxiety unless the party
might be separated in distant hostelries
our real anxiety became the possibility
of losing our way in the maze of halls
and corridors in the one hotel numerous
gas lights served to illuminate the
rooms and halls so that we could not
distinguish at all the coming of
darkness outside in the dining hall
there was such a spread of food of both
the woods and the sea but even those in
the mission who professed their dislike
of foreign objects could not maintain
this aversion in the choice of food the
joke was in the stock of Japanese
supplies brought along in our baggage we
could not cook our rice in the kitchen
of the hotel nor was it possible within
reason to use our oil wick lamps in the
horse
finally exhausted with all the useless
impediments we piled it all up in an
apartment and offered the entire stores
rice oil lamps and everything to one of
the lesser members of the welcoming
committee and asked him to take it for
free as we were unfamiliar with Western
life and customs there was naturally no
end of the farcical situations occurring
among our party when one of the Lord
envis had occasion to use the toilet he
was followed to the doorway by one of
his personal attendants who carried the
lighted paper lantern as is the custom
in our homeland the attendant in his
most formal dress was to be seen
squatting patiently outside the open
door holding his master's removed sword
this happened to be in the bustling
corridor of the hotel where people were
passing constantly and the gas was
burning as bright as day
but unperturbed sat the faithful
guardian I happened to come along and
see the incident which I ended by
shutting the doors and turning to the
man I told him quietly of the etiquette
of the Europeans on such occasions but
my heart was fluttering with
consternation of the political situation
of that time I tried to learn as much as
I could from various persons that I met
in London and Paris though it was often
difficult to understand things clearly
as I was as yet so unfamiliar with the
history of Europe however I find now as
I look in my diary the mention of
Napoleon the third is a very powerful
figure said to be the greatest statesman
of all Europe at that time then I find
mention of a great growing power Prussia
the neighbouring country with our
influence spreading like a Rising Sun
the wars with Austria and the problem of
alsace-lorraine were constantly
discussed and I remember they were made
the subject of prophecy by many men
while we were in London certain member
of the Parliament sent us a copy of a
bill which he said he had proposed in
the house under the name of the party
which he belonged the bill was a protest
against the arrogant attitude of the
British Minister to Japan Allcock who
had at times acted as if Japan were a
country conquered by military force one
of the instances mentioned in the bill
was out of all [ __ ] riding his horse
into the sacred temple grounds of Sheba
an unpardonable insult to the Japanese
on reading the copy of this bill I felt
as if a load had been lifted from my
chest
after all the foreigners were not all
Devils
I felt that Japan was enduring some
pointed affronts on the part of the
foreign ministers who presumed on the
ignorance of our government but now that
I had actually come to the minister's
native land I found that there were
among them some truly impartial and
warm-hearted human beings so after this
I grew even more determined in my
doctrine of free communication with the
rest of the world
a perplexing institution was
representative government when they
asked a gentleman what the election law
was and what kind of an institution the
Parliament really was he simply replied
with a smile meaning I suppose that no
intelligent person was expected to ask
such a question but these were the
things most difficult of all for me to
understand in this connection I learned
that there were different political
parties the liberal and the conservative
who were always fighting against each
other in the government for some time it
was beyond my comprehension to
understand what they were fighting for
and what was meant anyway by fighting in
peacetime this man and that man are
enemies in the house they would tell me
but these enemies were to be seen at the
same table eating and drinking with each
other I felt as if I could not take much
out of this it took me a long time with
some tedious thinking before I could
gather a general notion of these
separate mysterious facts some of the
more complicated matters I might achieve
an understanding five or ten days after
they were explained to me but all in all
I learned much from this initial tour of
Europe the country in Europe which gave
us the kindest welcome was Holland
which was a natural outcome of the very
special relationship which Japan had
enjoyed with Holland for the last 300
years moreover all the members of the
mission who knew any foreign language at
all had studied Dutch before any other
language so it made Holland so far as
the use of language was concerned seemed
like our second homeland there was I
recall an episode which was rather
significant one day in Amsterdam during
a conversation with some merchants and
other gentlemen our envoi chance to ask
the question is the sale and purchase of
land in Amsterdam freely permitted the
reply was certainly it is free do you
sell land to foreigners also yes as long
as a foreigner who's willing to pay for
that land we would sell any amount of it
to any person then suppose a foreigner
were to put down a large sum of money to
purchase a great tract of land in order
to build a fortress would you allow that
to the Hollanders looked puzzled at this
and replied we never have had occasion
to think of such a case even though
there are many rich men in England and
France and other lands we do not believe
any merchant would spend money on such a
venture
neither side understood the other we
interpreters were much amused by this
conversation it is not to be wondered at
that Japan was going through a hard
struggle when the control and handling
of foreign affairs were in the hands of
men who exhibited such reasoning in
their contact with the West one
ridiculous idea held by our embassy was
that its members should not meet the
foreigners or see the country any more
than they had to we were under the
seclusion theory even while we were
traveling in foreign territory
here by the way I I have to admit a
weakness of mine
I've always been lively and rather
inclined to being boastful but the truth
is I am of a timid nature when it comes
to putting a living thing to death or
seeing any kind of injury so while we
were in Russia this faint-hearted human
was taken to see a major surgical
operation my friends
Mizuki and Matt Sookie were eager to go
because they were both physicians by
profession they induced me to go along
in the operating room of the hospital
the surgeon in a kind of raincoat was
giving the patient chloroform on a table
which looked to me like a carving board
then he took her shining knife and
pierced the side of the patient Wow a
tremendous burst of blood shot out on
the raincoat of the surgeon the
operation was for a stone I kept on
looking at his movements until the
inserted an instrument like a pair of
pliers in the wound to lift out the
stone then I began to grow faint one of
my companions helped me out of the room
and gave me water ever since we had
started on the tour the auntie foreign
movement in Japan had been growing worse
and more and more blunders were being
made in our foreign diplomacy in Russia
our envoy's attempted to settle the
dispute over the border line I wasn't
present at the actual discussion of the
dispute so I know how they ridiculed our
protests our invoice thoughtfully spread
out their map and pointed out that
according to the diagram in which
Japanese territory was printed blue and
Russian territory who read the border
line would be such and such therefore
Japan would naturally claim all the land
within that line the Russians thereupon
retorted that if the colors on the map
were to decide the extent of national
territory they could easily claim the
whole world by painting the entire map
read this Pleasant raillery made it
impossible for the Japanese envoy's to
conclude any argument finally they were
obliged to resign their efforts
I felt thoroughly discouraged after
sitting through this negotiation
what hope for the future of Japan as
long as our people showed this
stiff-necked pride keeping aloof from
the actual give-and-take of the rest of
the civilized world the more this
movement of expel the foreigners
increased the more we would lose our
national power to say nothing of
prestige I was mortified when I thought
over the possible outcomes of national
exclusiveness one day it happened that I
had a conversation in private with a
member of the reception committee he
drew me alone into a separate room and
began to talk of my personal affairs I
do not know much about Japan possibly I
am not qualified to speak but from
general reasoning I feel that Japan is
not a country for an ambitious youth it
is a small country little opportunity
for doing big things what would you say
to settling yourself in Russia
I replied honestly as I felt I am in the
service of the embassy I cannot withdraw
and stay here as you suggest oh yes you
can easily answer the Russian if you
make up your mind to do so you can I
will hide you somewhere and the Japanese
would not be able to find you I could
strongly recommend you staying for there
are all sorts of occupations here you're
living is assured there is the chance of
making money even of becoming rich this
was spoken in all seriousness in the
quiet of a private room there was no
sign of any pretence or joking this
incident made its impression on me I'd
heard that Russia was different from all
the other countries of Europe now I
understood it for during my visits to
England and France and also in America
the year before nearly all the people I
talked with with
to come to Japan in fact I was often
bored by having people asked me find
them a job in Japan but I had not met
with anyone in those lands who advised
me to stay in his country I could guess
from the committee man's eagerness to
have me remain in Russia that it was
more than a mere personal idea probably
it was a political or diplomatic scheme
it might even have been an underhanded
venture we returned to France and we're
about to sail on the return voyage which
Japan when news of the namamugi affair
reached us suddenly the entire attitude
of Napoleon's government changed I do
not know what may have been the general
opinion of people over the affair but
the official attitude was decidedly cool
as we were about to take a boat we found
the guard of honor
lined all along the road for a distance
of almost a mile this we felt certain
was not purely a salute of farewell it
was a subtle demonstration of the French
military power as well naturally we did
not expect to be fired upon
but this insinuation of ill-will was
really too much to bear we drew in to
Lisbon and Portugal where the envoy's
had submission to complete then we
entered the Mediterranean then the
Indian Ocean and finally we returned
safely to our native Shores back in
Japan once more I found the country at
the height of the anti foreign sentiment
all Japan was now hopelessly swept by
this anti Western feeling and nothing
could stop its force from rushing to the
ultimate consequence until now this anti
foreign movement had been only an
existence in society separate from my
personal life but now since our return
from Europe the situation had changed
the Ronin were appearing in the most
unexpected places even some of the
merchants engaged in foreign trade
suddenly closed up their shops for fear
of these law
warriors the Ronin were behaving like
political ruffians and there was no
telling what they might be doing next
[Music]
you